we used to look up in the sky and wonder
at our place in the stars now you just
look down and worry about our place and
dirt so this is the place to be tonight
it's the BFI IMAX and the European
premiere of interstellar and the star of
that movie Matthew McConaughey
will be here to tell us all about the
year's most ambitious epic
interstella is the story of a group of
explorers who undertake the most
important mission in history to go to
another galaxy to find a planet that can
sustain human life because life on
planet earth is dying out we must
confront the reality that nothing in our
solar system can help us and they do
that in one of these now this is a
ranger this is actually one of the range
is used in the movie t-minus five hey
guys how important do you think it was
to make the film using IMAX technology
for there's any film that's ever really
really demanded a must-see trip to the
theater and IMAX it's it's interstellar
3 Chris did that guy consciously - and
nobody in the business it's more size
and scale on the screens Chris does one
here we go
they can't just think about your family
now you have to think bigger than that I
am thinking about my family and millions
of other families
what he shoots deserves IMAX because
it's a visual and audio experience you
might have to decide before seeing your
children again in the future of the
human race and so uh there's no there's
no tricks it's just that much more rich
yes you are yes you are